Also geht das Kommunikationssystem für medizinische Implantate online und wir versenden Menschen mit RFID.
Die Mac-Anleitungen.
Ich wurde 1979 mit einem in mir geboren.
Der starke Synthesizer ist der ohmige EEG-Gehirnanschluss, den wir verwenden, wenn wir uns an- und abmelden, weil man dann einen Loop läuft, der so nah ist wie Yannick vom maschinellen Lernen, auf den ich die Synergien hinweisen möchte.
Sie müssen nicht darüber lügen, was tatsächlich Ideen sind und was sie bewirken.
Es ist ein Derivat mit Medienzugriffskontrolle, und die Leute da draußen im Radiofrequenzbereich, die mit alten Geräten arbeiten oder nichts über den Körper oder das Netzwerk wissen, sagen, nun, wie verändert sich das ständig?
Weil Sie es mit WSM zu tun haben, bei denen es sich um drahtlose Sensornetzwerke in sehr kleinem Maßstab handelt, und sie bewegen sich, sprechen miteinander und kombinieren sich neu.
Oh, also hast du dich für maschinelles Lernen interessiert.
Er hat ziemlich viele Abonnenten und ehrlich wie ASEAN Tech auch.
Und sie sprechen von Neuron zu Neuron von Gehirn zu Gehirn.
Ich spreche davon, wo Sie wahrscheinlich die Sonne beobachten, die im Dezember 2022 untergegangen ist.
Oh ja.
Nun, die Chips in unserem Kopf im Jahr 2100, bevor irgendjemand Telepathie haben kann.
Wie praktisch.
Was ist, wenn du damit geboren wurdest?
Nun, sie werden es dir wegnehmen.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Nun, sie haben Gehirn-Bildgebungsbibliotheken wie Bill, um mit CRISPR-Cas9 Veränderungen an Ihren Proteinen, Ihren Peptiden, Ihren Aminoketten, Ihren Aminosäuren vorzunehmen.
Wir übertragen es also auf die Veränderung mit etwas, das Transkriptom genannt wird, und die Proteomik schreibt Ihre Proteine um, um Verbindungen herzustellen.
Auch hier geht es um das hirntötende Gehirn, das nach Cybersicherheitsstandards für die Übertragung von Informationen sicher sein muss.
Also jede einzelne Eizelle im Gehirn ist da drin und das Konnektom testet auf DNA-Sequenzmuster und wie Sie sich gegenüber anderen Menschen verhalten.
Wenn Sie glauben, dass Ihre Augen projizieren, befinden Sie sich tatsächlich im Backend eines Computers für den neuronalen Austausch von Neuronen und Ihr Plasma, natürlich, eine Struktur im Untergrund, die Ihrer DNA entspricht.
IBM-Computer.
Also, wer macht das alles?
Dieselben Leute, die ich immer gesehen habe.
Medizinische Versorgung, Polizei, Recht, Feuerwehr, wichtige militärische, paramilitärische, schwarze Projekte, Geodaten im Silicon Valley.
Mm hmm.
Und warum machen sie das?
Weil sie sich einfach mit Geo Mansur in deinen Hintern einloggen und deinen Standort mit ihren schönen, kleinen kuratierten Datenkennzeichnungs- und Datenkurationsdatenbanken bestimmen können.
Das DOD war auf der September-Konferenz für künstliche Intelligenz im September 2020 ausverkauft.
Ziemlich erstaunlich, erklärt Polya von Ruanda, wie wir hinuntergegangen sind und Nano in Aerosol in die Luft geschossen haben.
Aber wir brauchen eine sichere Kommunikation zwischen bestimmten Soldaten.
Und dafür modifizieren Sie die Biosensoren der ATO 2.15.6.
Sie können sie vor der chemischen Kriegsführung oder der Aerosolisierung retten, indem Sie verschiedene Arten von bioelektrischem Code eingeben und drahtloses Tissue Engineering Heilen durchführen.
Und dann können die drahtlosen Sensornetzwerke all den anderen Menschen mitteilen, dass Sie auf die gleiche Weise etwas anderes tun möchten.
Die Zaubersprüche, die wir auf Leute anwenden, wenn sie unsere Zauberbücher im Get Hub speichern, habe ich Vektor- oder Merkmalswerte, wenn sie wirksam werden oder nachdem sie die Koordinate mit der Antwort erreicht haben, und diese Merkmalswerte sind deine Ziffern-ID, also könnten sie alles sein.
Und wir bestellen eine Drohne, machen mit dem Zugriff, den wir haben, in Echtzeit ein Foto über Ihrem Zuhause und dann können wir ein generatives gegnerisches neuronales Netzwerk starten, ein künstliches neuronales Netzwerk oder was auch immer wir wollen, und die Luftmoleküle um Ihren Kopf herum durch Stromschlag töten.
Es hat Terahertz-Kugeln ausgeführt oder was auch immer wir wollen, und das wirst du verstecken.
Drei nochmal, Positionsnavigation und Timing Ihrer Biosensoren.
AUTO 2.15.4.
Fangen Sie an zu sehen, dass es eine verdammt große Sache ist, die Sie gemacht haben.
Jeder hat nach der Cloud gefragt und ihnen nichts gesagt.
Und dann hatten wir, naja, du kannst Schmerzen einfach nicht aushalten.
Oh, es ist ein falscher Gehirntumor, aber wir wissen nicht warum.
Oh, du hast Anfälle, bei denen deine Augen blutunterlaufen.
Wir wissen nicht warum.
Lupus, Lou-Gehrig-Syndrom, all die Autoimmunerkrankungen, alles.
Wir können nichts tun, wenn man Menschen durch ihr eigenes Gewebe durch einen Stromschlag tötet und man es ihnen nicht sagt und ihr Immunsystem zwingt, sich elektrisch an Nanotechnologie oder einen anderen Körper zu binden, und zwar auf eine andere elektrische Art als das, was Ihre roten Blutkörperchen und Ihre Neuronen zum Funktionieren benötigen.
Am Ende bekommst du eine Autoimmunerkrankung, ein automatisches Immunproblem mit der Reihenfolge der Operation, weil du ihnen einen Stromschlag gibst.
Ja, das machen die Biosensoren.
Oh, also jetzt, weil niemand etwas über subtile Stromschläge gesagt hat, ist deine Nano-Morgellons-Krebsgeschichte nicht meine Geschichte zu erzählen, aber sie erzählen dir in der Daily Mail den Krebs.
Nimm es in 15 Minuten weg.
Wenn ich diese Fähigkeit seit 1995 hätte.
Jetzt ist es das Syndrom des plötzlichen Todes bei Erwachsenen.
Fick dich.
Schwerwiegend und ohne Rechenschaftspflicht für all diese Tests, die sie mit den Impfungen auf den verschiedenen Altersskalen durchgeführt haben.
Nichts davon.
Nicht ein verdammtes bisschen davon.
Also, womit sind wir am Ende gekommen?
Vollständiger Kreis.
Das kleine Personal Area Network mit sechs Gramm.
Dein Hintern hängt an der Wolke.
Das Signal verbreitet sich von dir, deinem Körper, deiner DNA.
Mach das Signal für einen Ochsen aus und töte deine Lieben vor deinem Gesicht.
Stoppen Sie Ihre DNA.
Und das ist erschreckend.
Das ist wirklich überzeugend.
Ja, das ist Cybersicherheit.
Stoppen Sie das Signal.
Sie müssen die DNA stoppen, weil der Körper oder Ihr Netzwerk das Signal herkommt.
Es wird also nicht verschwinden, wenn Sie die DNA nicht stoppen.
Also du Radiofrequenz.
Die Leute denken, Sie möchten sich vielleicht über eine Technologie von 1995 informieren, wenn das wirklich die Situation ist, in der wir uns befinden.
Weil die Metamaterialien dabei sind, einen Transhumanen sehr ernst zu nehmen.
Und ich werde weitermachen und das Metamaterial erneut aufrufen, nur für dich.
Radiofrequenz, Hände und Menschen.
Ich habe großen Respekt vor euch.
Ich bin sehr überrascht.
Wenn du es nicht weißt, ist jetzt der richtige Zeitpunkt.
Aber genau wie die Typen auf den Hobbyfarmen haben wir alle in deinem Keller rumgehangen.
Immer noch coole Sachen, wie du es mit deiner Ausrüstung machst, um sie zu testen, und genau wie die Typen von Bubba Black Sheep, die ihre Drohnen aus guten Gründen fliegen lassen und versuchen, jungen Leuten beizubringen, wie cool es ist, selbst eine Leiterplatte zu bauen und sie kommunizieren zu lassen.
Und sie haben alles zur Waffe gemacht, dass es super hässlich ist und es sehr schwierig ist, mit jemandem über dieses Zeug zu kommunizieren.
Und vor allem jetzt, da die neue Kriegstechnologie elektrisch ist und das bedeutet, dass Telepathie, Empathie und Präkognition, natürliche Fähigkeiten und Humanität, heute heiß begehrt sind.
Niemand versteht, was vor sich geht, weil Sie nicht zugeben werden, dass sie ein cyberphysisches Backbone geschaffen haben, weil sie mehr Durchsatz benötigten.
Und mein Schild dafür fehlt aus irgendeinem Grund.
Also werde ich damit zurückkommen.
Es ist synthetische Biologie.
Bitte schauen Sie sich meine Videos zur synthetischen Biologie an, um das Glossar und die Begriffe zu finden, und danke Ihnen für die Menschen, die Nanoarbeit als Kontaktpunkt nutzen.
Und ich hoffe, das ist die einfache Erklärung, die dir gegenüber nicht zickig klingt.
Ich bin einfach so wütend, dass sie niemandem gesagt haben, dass es ein Körperteil ist, denn wie Sie sehen können, schalten Sie, wenn Sie wieder zur Cybersicherheit zurückkehren, Ihre DNA aus, denn das werden sie hören wollen.
Also lass uns dann das W erziehen und dein Körperteil damals nehmen.
Was mache ich mit all dem?
BioFilm-Praxis.
Ich weiß, dass du das nicht hören willst, aber es ist die Wahrheit.
Es ist dein Körperteil.
Du weißt am besten, wie es funktioniert.
Und wenn Sie wüssten, dass Präkognition und Empathie hier die beiden häufigsten Neuronen oder Fähigkeiten sind, dann ist das nicht psychisch, sondern psi-ionisch.
Deshalb ist meine Website Synergie.
PSI plus Energie entspricht Synergie wie in Ihrem eigenen Biofeld, Ihren eigenen psionischen Fähigkeiten, meinen eigenen Neuronen.
Ich brauche kein Wearable, um Telepath oder Telekinetiker zu sein.
Sie praktizieren bewusst drahtloses Tissue Engineering.
Das bedeutet, Ihr Wachstum und Ihre inneren Organe zu unterdrücken und Ihr Gehirngewebe zu hemmen.
Keine Babys.
Wenn wir also tatsächlich einen Weg finden wollen, müssen die Leute ehrlich darüber sein, was bereits eingesetzt wurde und was mit dem Wide Body Area-Netzwerk im Spiel ist.
Wir können es uns nicht leisten, weiter herumzualbern, Sensorjäger zu schützen und so zu tun, als würde es besser werden.
Die Leute, die wollen, dass sich diese Systeme ändern, sind nichts.
Sie werden nicht ermordet, aber seit über 20 Jahren und sie wollen mich alle 5 Minuten ermorden.
Also gehe ich jetzt spazieren.
Gott segne euch alle da draußen.
Ich muss noch andere Videos laden, die ich gerade lade.
Ich lade diese zuerst für die Leute, die wirklich gefragt haben, Kannst du es bitte für mich aufschlüsseln?
So einfach wie möglich.
Mark 536 Sogar.